the backlash to the supreme court's
decision to throw out roe versus wade
has taken on new shapes one day after
kansas voters rejected a measure to
remove abortion rights from the state's
constitution president biden announced a
new executive order to assist abortion
seekers
stephen portnoy cbs news radio looks at
the potential for major ripple effects
in the midterm and beyond
itself we're going to get through this
difficult period the loss has left
conservatives flat footed this is
absolutely surprised and i have no
explanation and
again it was just a gut punch more than
900 thousand kansans cast ballots
tuesday a stunning turnout for an early
august primary hi how are you the defeat
of the proposed constitutional amendment
which was aimed at undoing the effects
of a state supreme court decision
girding abortion rights shows not only
how the issue has galvanized democrats
but how it could also threaten
republicans take a look at leavenworth
county in 2020 59 percent of voters
there chose former president trump the
same percentage voted no on tuesday and
in sedgwick county the state's second
most populous 54 voted for donald trump
58 percent voted against the amendment
to those of us who watch politics that
abortion is not as polarizing
as really really we think patrick miller
is a political science professor at the
university of kansas on this one issue
when they were allowed the opportunity
to vote on abortion
they did so and they expressed their
preference the latest cbs news poll
shows women under 50 see abortion as
their top issue heading into the
midterms and most democrats say their
party isn't doing enough to protect
abortion access this fall voters in
vermont and california will be asked
whether they support codifying abortion
rights in their state's constitutions
kentucky voters will weigh an amendment
similar to the one just defeated in
kansas and in montana republicans have
proposed an amendment requiring care for
any infants that might survive attempted
abortions on wednesday president biden
said the kansas result proves abortion
opponents have misjudged voters anger i
have a clue about the power of american
women
last night in congress in kansas they
found out
president biden's comments yesterday
came as he signed his second executive
order aimed at protecting abortion
rights this order directs the department
of health and human services to see
about using medicaid funds to help
low-income women access abortions out of
state michelle
stephen thank you